- Well, when you're not
in Big Sky, how do you,
'cause we just moved here,
how do you like wind down here?
- Do you like to sweat?
- Um, I like hiking, if
that's where you're going.
- No.
- Oh, okay.
- No, this is--
- If you're going like spinning, I'm out.
- No, not spinning.
You lay on a table.
- [Kelly] I'm in.
- It's like an urban (laughing)--
- Yeah, I'm in.
- It's an urban sweat lodge.
- What?
- You lay on a table.
They wrap you like a burrito.
It heats up.
They put headphones on.
You can watch Amazon, Hulu, Netflix.
They bring you water.
- Okay, you're just sweating out toxins,
listening to music or a movie.
- Yes, and your heart rate
goes up and you burn calories,
laying there watching TV. (laughing)
- We found it!
We found the miracle.